hey what's up guys mkbhd here fun fact
people
still use blackberries a recent poll
from the boy genius report showed that
the current u.s usage share of
smartphones for blackberry is
one percent it was measured from mobile
web data usage which means basically in
layman's terms that one percent of all
the phones that are going on the
internet nowadays are blackberries but
how much is that really well there are
300 million people living in the united
states and roughly 115 million of those
people in 2012 are smartphone owners and
we'll call blackberry smartphones for
this so one percent of these 115 million
smartphone owners are blackberries that
means there are 1.15
million people using blackberries today
in the united states that's a lot of
people now taking a look at this chart
it shows that as recently as october
2011 more than five percent of people
using smartphones were blackberries so
now that's more than a 75 percent drop
off in just less than a year but they're
still afloat there's still a million of
them why so many well you have to
consider the fact that a lot of the
people who are using blackberries are
people who got them because of
enterprise that's a huge market that
blackberry and rim used to hold most
people who are getting jobs that give
out phones they give their employees a
blackberry to use and if you want to use
the phone for personal use you can buy
another one but a lot of employees are
getting blackberries for free to use for
their business five to guess i'd say
that's about 75
of the blackberries that are being used
in the us which leaves about 250 000
people who are using blackberries by
choice or because they can't afford
anything else or they're locked into a
contract right now some of these people
are really difficult to understand like
i could understand if your business
forces you to use a blackberry for
business and you can't really afford
anything else or if you use a second
phone for more personal use but if
you're one of the maybe 100 or 150 000
people that chooses to use a blackberry
over anything else for the price
that's confusing to me did you know that
in the united states on verizon the
blackberry bold 9930 costs the same as
the samsung galaxy nexus
anyway here's a little graphic i put
together a very short one that
summarizes the state of research in
motion the company that's behind
blackberry
[Music]
i kid i kid rim you're doing all right
okay you got a million people that's
solid here look i have a blackberry with
me right now i promise i don't use any
other devices it's just the one that i
happen to prefer it's a neat little
device it's very pocketable i have this
other random phone here don't know how
it got here but it it fits in the screen
of this other device it's how
pocketable it is and it has a keyboard
and it has a camera on the back i think
that's a
one megapixel camera um the screen is
about
an inch
or two
maybe that's all you really need is a
little keyboard right here you can hear
the clicks
they're very tactile and stuff and
that's what it's all about with
blackberries isn't it look at that it's
hefty
it's the bulk you need either way i'm
back to doing regular videos guys in
case you haven't noticed i am back from
my one week break thanks for watching
this video if you enjoyed it feel free
to give it a thumbs up as that does help
out a lot and subscribing if you want to
see more videos uh and of course your
comments are going to be answered in the
comment section right below that like
button so i'll talk to you guys in the
next video thanks for watching
peace
[Music]
you